people don't see the work me and Andrew
we're in good shape I don't post
training videos and you know Fitness
progress videos I just do the work and
let the results speak for itself in
terms of money and in terms of business
and success that's Andrew everyone's
like oh well how does he have all this
money maybe he's a criminal so uh how
does he have all this money I know why
he has all this money this month because
he's sitting right there at that desk at
least 10 hours a day even when we're not
on house arrest he'll be out in the
evenings having his fun and that's what
we'll show to the world this whole hey
look at me I'm at my laptop and I'm
going to grind away for six hours like
that's no one wants to see that on
Instagram no one wants to see that on
social media it's boring they want to
see you driving the Bugatti with a cigar
in your mouth and a beautiful girl next
to you but that doesn't come without
sitting at that desk for a good while
first